l'irak post saddam hussein on en parle
justement avec adel bat kahone il est
directeur du centre français de
recherche sur l'irak et auteur de l'irak
un siècle de faillite de 1921 à nos
jours bonjour adel bat kahone tous
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être sur ce
plateau avec nous sur rt france on a vu
l'irak post saddam hussein où il ya eu
des guerres et évidemment le terrorisme
de l'état islamique qui s'en est suivie
aujourd'hui qu'en est il de cette irak
indépendante sur le papier qu'en est il
dans les faits
dramatiques
dramatique pourquoi parce que tout
simplement le lot pays se trouve dans
une situation de faillite faillite
économique fight militaire faillite
sociale faillite étatique aujourd'hui la
situation vraiment est dramatique vous
avez dans le nord d'irak la turquie dans
une offensive jour après jour avec une
installation doute 33 base militaire
très très intensive dans l'otan l'eau
dans le sud vous avez le déploiement
massif des organisations milicienne et
qui sont estimés à
160 mille combattants qui sont aussi
dits son shit dans le territoire le pays
des sunnites il y a le retour en force
de l'organisation état islamique à
l'échelle régionale vous avez une
domination presque totale iranienne en
irak à l'échelle internationale vous
avez le désengagement presque totale des
états unis d'amérique le fello pays est
livré à ses propres démons livrer à ses
propres démons est néanmoins convoité
vous l'avez dit par par les grandes
puissances par les voisins les états
unis en premier chef l'iran la turquie
également alors qu'ils coûtaient de 2003
à 2021 layrac nous disposent pas en soi
des infrastructures pour fonctionner en
tant qu'etat souverain lawson éléments
qui maintient encore l'unité du pays
l'unité territoriale du pays c'est la
volonté des états unis d'amérique et de
la république islamique de l'iran est à
la marge de l'union européenne autrement
dit c'est c'est un élément extérieur
c'est la volonté des pays du système
international si cette volonté n'est
plus là aujourd'hui le lendemain il y
aura plus d'irak aujourd'hui à l'état
pratique on a bien observé les résultats
des élections de 10 octobre n'est ce pas
exactement il y a eu des élections en
irak et à ce jeu lorsqu on analyse ces
données factuelles on comprend
rapidement que nous n'avons pas des
élections nationales nous avons des
élections
territorialisée je vous donne un seul
exemple les 63 nous tenons les 73 sièges
de morta d'assad obtenu quelques idées
xi qui a gagné les chutes il n'y a pas
un seul siège dans le nord kurde un seul
siège dans le centre sunnite pareil par
exemple pour les 33 sièges ou 31 sièges
du barzani loupé dakkak le parti
démocratique du kurdistan dans le nord
dans le kurdistan irakien il n'y a pas
un seul siège dans le territoire sous
need ou chez autrement dit vous avez
trois élections trois champs politique à
je pourrais même parlé d'un état
considéré et qui correspond à un
découpage
ethnique et confessionnelle des
confessions et irakiennes sunnites
kurdes et chiites bien entendu les
etats-unis sont toujours présentes en
irak pour quelle raison est ce que ce
sont pour des raisons d' avantages
économiques
je dirais géopolitique alors on nous
parle de des troupes combattantes ceux
des états unis d'amérique qui quittent
le pays demain leur trente et un espace
vendredi 1 mais en réalité depuis fin
2000 17 janvier 2018 il n'ya plus des
troupes combattantes américaines sur le
sol irakien ce qui se passe actuellement
ici et maintenant c'est un cadeau c'est
dans le cadeau de la part de la maison
blanche à un premier ministre qui
s'appelle mustapha kazmi a faibli
fragile fragilisée dans les rapports de
force à l'intérieur du champ politique
irakien on lui offre on lui fait ce
cadeau pour pouvoir s'imposer aux autres
acteurs pro iranien
sinon elle est à pratiquer les états
unis d'amérique militairement parlant
autant que ne une armée ou des troupes
combattantes n'est plus là mais par
contre les états unis d'amérique à la
plus grande ambassade ambassade au monde
en irak encore en irak le plus grand
consulat au monde se trouve à erbil 1 et
donc les états unis et sont encore en
irak massivement avec une présence
massive pourquoi pour des raisons
géopolitiques pourquoi parce que tout
simplement les états unis d'amérique à
ce jour là ne peuvent pas se désengager
et ce sont des engagés militairement
économique mais pas économiquement mais
pas mais pas mes pages géopolitiquement
pourquoi parce que tout simplement leur
présence pour la production des pays du
golfe avoir un oeil sur la république
islamique d'iran avoir un oeil sur la
turquie tout ça c'est des nécessités
géopolitique je vous parlais des
élections législatives on a vu le parti
de moqtada al-sadr parti chiite mais qui
n'est pas forcément alliée à l'iran qui
a qui est sorti vainqueur de ces
élections est la perte d' influence de
l'iran se traduit par ces législatives
selon vous alors non ça c'est elle la
première lecture des résultats de ces
élections en termes de sièges oui mais
en termes de la base militante de la
base sociale non pourquoi parce qu'on
fait lorsqu'on analyse le nombre des
personnes qui ont voté pour les pro
iranien dépasse largement le nombre des
personnes qui ont voté pour morte à
d'assad ce qui s'est passé c'est là la
raison la gestion pragmatique et
rationnelle de ces élections il y a eu
une nouvelle loi électorale les
appareils doublera d'assad qui avait une
grande expérience dans la gestion de ces
élections-là 12 de cette nouvelle loi
ont parfaitement réparti à leur base
électorale sur les différentes villes et
les différents districts or les pro
iranien n'avait pas cette expérience je
vous donne un exemple à peu près le
nombre de votants pour mourtada sadriste
est estimé à 900 milles or le nombre des
votants pour les pro iranien le dépasse
un million quatre cent mille il ya la
turquie aussi qui entrent dans le jeu
vous avez parlé des bases militaires au
kurdistan irakien pour quelles raisons
tout d'abord il ya la question du pkk le
parti des travailleurs du kurdistan qui
est en guerre contre la turquie depuis
des années 80 n'est ce pas alors
aujourd'hui la base la base militaire à
de dieu kaka se trouvent dans des
montagnes ou qu'un deal qui se trouve au
kurdistan irakien ça c'est la première
raison la deuxième raison bien
évidemment ce sont les ambitions turques
lecture non jamais oui voilà les l'irak
dans ces trois provinces bashir à bagdad
et mossoul appartenait à l'empiré
ottoman n'est ce pas et la turquie n'a
jamais antérieures risée
lalalalala l'annexion de la provence de
nos sols à l'irak moderne
c'est pourquoi la turquie a toujours un
oeil sur numéro trois c'est la
communauté sunnite la turquie se
présente comme le producteur la
productrice de la communauté sunnite qui
se trouve dans la province de mossoul et
bien évidemment il y as est
conflictuelle iter entre la domination
turque et à la domination italienne sur
le sol irakien un mot sur cette
communauté sunnite dont les anciens
membres du parti baas de saddam hussein
sont en majorité aller dans la dans la
rébellion ou dans le terrorisme
islamique de l'état islamique qu'en est
il aujourd'hui de cette menace alors la
menace de l'organisation d' états
islamiques absolue la menace revient en
force on a bien remarqué au en trois
semaines il y avait plusieurs attaques
il ya eu plusieurs prises en otages
plusieurs grands développements
plusieurs assassinats donc
l'organisation d' états islamiques son
retour en force est vraiment une données
factuelles numéro en numéro 10 pour la
communauté sunnite et je m'arrête là il
y à une réorganisation politique a entre
deux pôles le pôle d'eau albeau si
l'actuel président de l'assemblée
nationale et le pôle de rami se ranger
qui est dans l'opposition
autrement dit auparavant 2021 on n'avait
pas cette organisation politique de la
communauté sunnite mais depuis l'échec
de l'état islamique on assiste à cette
réorganisation politique de l'aide de la
communauté sunnite merci beaucoup adel
bat kahone d'avoir répondu
à à mes questions en direct sur arte
france aujourd'hui merci ce un dialogue